okay you're going to the uh you're
covering the winter olympics yes oh my
god i'm so excited
[Applause]
is there anyone that you're so excited
there's a million people it's going to
be great i mean usually the whole today
show goes to the olympics because of
kovid i know i remember you went to
japan yeah towards you around the bus
yes we did oh yes covet has changed the
olympic just like it changes everything
but not the competition so the today
show is actually going to basically do
an olympic plaza we have athletes come
by fire pits we're going to like do it
up on the show so you can cover you know
follow all the olympics but i'm really
looking forward to i love figure skating
sorry it's my favorite my favorite do
you remember there was a skater named
nathan chen and in pyeongchang he was
the guy that everyone's like he's gonna
meddle he's perfect yes he did not have
the results he he wanted and it was a
huge disappointment and do you know what
he's done pretty much every competition
since then ace it he's won yeah and he's
back and i really am just so rooting for
him i want him to have his redemption
well and i swear if there's anything
better than an olympic package that's a
background story on people you get so
invested that is the best storytelling
ever well all of these olympians every
single one has an incredible story to
get there takes so much determination so
much grit everyone's overcome obstacles
there's not anyone who hasn't put their
heart their soul everything on the line
day after day year after year for this
one second so the there you don't even
have to manufacture any drama it's right
there you don't and it's also like these
are just these are good hard-working
talented people who poured themselves
into a goal and it's so fun to watch
them shine i love it when i watch with
the girls i the whole time i keep saying
to them like
the pressure is that everything leads up
to this moment you can work for five
years and it is judged within five
minutes
and that to put yourself in that kind of
line of work that's pressure
the craziest i don't know how they do it
honestly i i don't know but i can't wait
to see you take us through it all and i
have to
before
okay
you have a new show that we're gonna go
to commercial and we're gonna come back
and talk all about because i'm so
excited for this show i watched the
first episode you should come on the
cooking show i want to you can teach me
to cook i want to you have a cookbook i
do and mine's rebel homemaker yes and
yours is starting from scratch yes we're
doing i also want to come on so we have
a tattoo cooking show what else can we
do
[Music]